[Música]
ahora quiero presentarles a nuestro
siguiente invitado como rodrigo rodrigo
bellot director de cine escritor
director de teatro
no voy a leer un director de teatro
actor empresario
represente bien o me faltó me faltó algo
te faltó lo más importante también soy
hijo soy hermanos y tíos soy amigo y
también soy gay
i
[Aplausos]
empezamos bien
primera vez que lo decís oficialmente
creo que si yo nunca había escuchado la
verdad es que nunca pensé que sea
necesario decirlo públicamente y bueno
hasta ahora
bueno
ahora sí
te saludo como la gente como está
rodrigo feliz feliz de estar aquí es un
sueño hecho realidad y además que
encontrarse en el mejor momento de mi
vida mío
sé que has tenido muchísimos buenos
momentos en tu vida porque este es el
momento de tu vida porque estoy a punto
de cumplir 40 años de transformaciones y
aprendizajes que me han permitido de
alguna manera no tener que esconder nada
no tener que temer nada y me permiten
hoy en día estar frente a ti ya todos
ustedes sin ningún filtro sabes este
cuando uno es niño se empieza a firmar
ya reconocerse a partir lo que uno ve lo
exterior lo visible lo que uno aprende
del día a día y a veces cuando uno es
algo que es diferente a eso que es
visible un hombre no es normal uno
empieza a negarlo y empieza a rechazarlo
ya esconderlo sin darnos cuenta de que a
veces eso que escondemos es lo más
valioso que tenemos como seres humanos
y lo que escondemos lo crees que lo
negamos porque lo consideramos que no es
normal y en este contexto de todas las
charlas que hemos escuchado hasta ahora
en el tiempo que vivimos es una pregunta
que parece obvia pero que es normal
[Música]
esa palabra caetano veloso dice que de
cerca nadie es normal y estoy plenamente
de acuerdo la normalidad es una ficción
una ilusión nada es como
el sistema operativo de tu computadora
todos tenemos una computadora y el
escritorio en el texto de tu computadora
pero es una ilusión porque en realidad
está diseñado para controlar tus
necesidades y tus aplicaciones pero
están sujetas a un contexto muy
subjetivo que es tu experiencia de vida
y tus necesidades pero nosotros somos
seres humanos expansivos de cambio
nuestro cerebro se expande y por eso es
que necesitamos hacer actualizaciones de
nuestro sistema operativo de cuando en
cuando
muchos de los que están escuchando se
preguntarán que voy a abrir mi mente voy
a hacer un menos juzgador etcétera pero
como como podemos realmente actualizar
evolucionar abrir nuestra mente de
verdad como actualizamos esa normalidad
a través de la conexión conociendo gente
diferente viajando leyendo y saliendo de
tu zona de confort
pintando fuera del margen de lo que es
la normalidad
uno se da cuenta que es diferente entre
los 4 y 6 años y no es una cuestión
sexual para nada es algo mucho más
complejo algo mucho más profundo y bueno
yo miraba el mundo de una manera muy
diferente desde chico mi padre decía que
era porque era fantasioso y de esa
manera alguna manera aproveché para
negar todas las cosas que yo intuía a
través de la imaginación y por eso
empezó mi fascinación con el cine con el
teatro con la literatura y esa
fascinación se convirtió en vocación
pero ahí apareció justamente el primer
no él no se puede hacer sin en bolivia
no hay referentes del cine boliviano no
existe ningún boliviano nominado al
oscar no se puede vivir del cine
boliviano él no fue tan persistente fue
tan recurrente que
efectivamente uno se empieza a
acostumbrar a eso para mí
uno se empieza a acostumbrar y le tiene
le pierde el miedo al no no y así sin
planificarlo un día me nominan al oscar
estudiantil cuando tengo 20 años y a mi
21 años empezó a dirigir mi primer
largometraje y sin pedirlo ni quererlo
empiezo a uno a salir en los periódicos
se sale en la televisión y de repente
todo el mundo siente el derecho a saber
más de voz
quieren saber cada detalle y ahí es
donde tu secreto corre peligro y ahí es
donde nosotros nos hacemos a veces mucho
más daño y empiezas en negociación entre
lo público y lo privado
y qué te pasó entonces después de todo
eso fuiste
cuando creo que cuando la vida se da
cuenta que tú te rechazas y que tú te
niegas se deshace de ti como si fueras
una aplicación en un software que ya no
tiene servicio utilidad que ya está
caducado de alguna manera y de esa
manera la vida actual rodrigo del miedo
mató al rodrigo del no
y ya cuando decís mato
metafóricamente o literalmente digo
literalmente
el convenio tenía 27 años tuve mi primer
novio aquí en bolivia y fue muy lindo
pero a pesar de todo nunca podíamos ir
al cine e ir a cenar juntos o en ningún
ningún espacio público siempre tenía que
haber una amiga que esté entre nosotros
para no despertar sospechas y llegó un
día en que recibí una llamada de un
periodista de un periódico importante
diciéndome que iban a publicar una foto
de nosotros dos que habían tomado en un
cumpleaños sin nuestro permiso y en ese
momento la vida de mi novio corría
peligro y mi carrera corría peligro y en
ese momento nuestras familias que sin
conocerse tenían una conexión ambos se
iban a enfrentar a lo que en ese momento
era y sigue siendo una vergüenza pública
yo pedía ayuda a cuánta gente pude
encontrar y no se logró publicar esa
foto
pero el rumor fue tan grande que llegó a
la familia de mi novio y al día
siguiente lo mandaron a europa y desde
entonces no ha vuelto al país no
siquiera pude despedirme de él pero él
logró enviarme su reloj y a través de un
amigo pidiéndome tiempo y paciencia
por eso los relojes
así es
[Aplausos]
casi nadie se da cuenta de que uso hace
más de años dos relojes pero más allá de
eso de darme tiempo y paciencia a mí
mismo en mi vida
este señor
amenazó de matarme si me encontraba en
la calle yo no está acostumbrado a
escuchar estas amenazas día a día y casi
no les da importancia para este momento
fue muy grave y yo pedía ayuda a las
naciones unidas y las naciones unidas me
dijeron de que efectivamente podía pedir
auxilio político pero que no me lo
recomendaban porque de esa manera no
podría regresar a bolivia nunca más y un
exilio te destruye el alma entonces yo
me fui a nueva york a sanar curiosamente
ahora me doy cuenta de que eso es una
opción que yo tuve y que mucho la gran
mayoría de las jóvenes acá no tienen de
salir para sanar
a los al año año y medio yo regresé a
recibir un premio a la mejor película
del año y en la misma noche del premio
con premio humano me esperaban tres
hombres en mi casa en el departamento de
la paz y me atacaron me dejaron muerto
en la calle con 34 fracturas de cráneo y
gracias a dios me encontró un vecino
ensangrentado llama a la ambulancia y me
dice y bueno me revivieron en la
ambulancia y días después de una especie
de coma yo desperté y ese día un 11 de
septiembre del 2009 nace el rodrigo del
cid me di cuenta de que si alguien
quiere matarse matarte por quién eres
tiene que haber algo maravilloso
extraordinario poderoso dentro tuyo
y él
y fue así que se convirtió en mi
superpoder como le digo a mi sobrino no
me di cuenta de que no tenía que perder
el tiempo
entonces ese momento me intenté
sin ni siquiera salir del hospital
dirigí un videoarte aprendí a caminar de
nuevo aprendí a bañarme por mí mismo a
cruzar la calle a cosas básicas mientras
tanto estaba escribiendo y de esa manera
poco tiempo me voy a vivir a ámsterdam
pero esta vez pecado no exiliado
es como que todo eso que te hicieron
cuando ya se destapó toda esa energía
que guardaba en eso que esconde como
dice tu charla somos lo que escondemos
cuando viste todo eso es como que haya
hayas dejado de gastarte todo ese
presupuesto energético en dejar de
controlar en dejar de temer y lo hayas
usado
todo ese recurso para hacer cosas
grandes tan grande como lo que recién
posea stevie que varias personas lo
compartieron de que fuiste elegido por
fast company de las revistas más
prestigiosas en el mundo de los negocios
entre las 100 personas más creativas en
el mundo de los negocios punto es los
más y varios de ese calibre
[Aplausos]
es cuando se libera esa energía
muchas gracias me encanta que hables en
términos empresariales porque justamente
me dicen porque rodrigo bellot está en
la lista de los más creativos del
business y yo creo que es que me di
cuenta en este momento en esta instancia
de que los premios los reconocimientos
al igual que los bienes materiales son
pasivos y que tu mayor activo en
realidad es el tú mismo no el más
importante activo eres tú mismo
me acuerdo algo que leí recién
de lo que la diferencia entre el
aprendizaje por capitalización que es el
más obvio son buenos en algo te gusta el
golf
lee le hace es no titubea te convertís
en tiger woods pero también existe el
otro tipo de aprendizaje que es menos
obvio que es el aprendizaje por
compensación a diferencia de
capitalización y el por compensación es
el que tiene que ver con esto de que de
lo que me llamo de nuestros complejos de
los de las de eso más íntimo surge una
fuerza desbordante que mucha gente como
vos o que lo han etiquetado mucho o que
lo han en tu caso intentado matar se
salvan y de pronto agarran un poder
impresionante ese aprendizaje por
compensación es uno de los más más
fuertes y pocos lo usamos a nuestro
favor
eso es lo que estás hablando de alguna
manera claro que sí me encanta la
tecnología no sé si has escuchado vos
sobre la pirámide de la pirámide de
jerarquía de necesidades de abraham
maslow básicamente si no tienes resuelta
tu supervivencia física tu autoestima
tus relaciones con otros tus relaciones
contigo mismo cómo te ves cómo te
perciben tus conexiones
si no tienes resueltas tus partes
básicas no puedes pasar a la próxima y
así en esta escala de cosas si no
resuelves una no puedes pasar a la otra
como niveles en un videojuego y ahí es
donde yo hablo también de la ley de
atracción de maxwell que dice que no
atraes lo que quieres
atraes lo que eres entonces si estás en
una fase de miedo atraes escla
exactamente eso miedo
y para pasar desde la parte teórica del
miedo voz ha sentido miedo vos ves la
cara cuando alguien tiene miedo vos ves
poder reconocer la cara que cuando
alguien esconde algo y tiene miedo
contanos un poco sobre ese tipo de miedo
no sé si puede reconocerlo en otras
personas pero te digo el miedo es ese
auto cumplidor por qué
el miedo lo que hace cuando nos tenemos
que enfrentar hacia algo que nos da
miedo el miedo al desconocido
nos vemos en esa imperiosa necesidad de
ir más allá de nosotros mismos más allá
de nuestra base de datos que tenemos en
la mente que aprendimos de chicos de
expander nuestra perspectiva y de alguna
manera pensar críticamente pero el miedo
lo que hace es exactamente lo opuesto el
miedo lo que hace es te incita una
retirada profunda dentro de tu mente
distorsiona tu vista distorsiona tu
perspectiva y te ahoga de alguna manera
tu pensamiento crítico y te llena te
inunda de
y emociones tóxicas perjudiciales
alguien decía que
pariente de la negación y primo hermano
del orgullo el miedo
se aferra al status quo y por eso es que
el miedo siempre sale cuando estamos
enfrentándonos a la acción a cambiar a
trascender a emprender a ser mejores a
evolucionar sin embargo
ante el miedo y vencidos aceptamos esa
realidad que nos ha creado el miedo ni
la cuestionamos subimos que es real
y ahí es donde uno de alguna manera se
porta bien ábrica responsabilidad culpa
a todos y a otros y como siempre digo
terceriza su destino
tú me man
y no
es un símbolo de cómo ese miedo lo
convertiste en algo trascendente porque
fue una de las obras más taquilleras que
han habido
y el impacto que causó en mucha gente es
un símbolo tú me manco
mira tú me man que es muy importante
porque es algo que ahora yo denomino
ingeniería narrativa
el 2014 yo pierdo muere mi mejor amigo
gandalf un hombre extraordinario que
además quería personalmente enseñarle a
volar a las gallinas
y meses después
pierdo a otro novio esta vez una vez más
por homofobia por miedo por ignorancia y
en esta pérdida más grande de mi vida
dos perdidas en un año lo que él se
suicidó
de alguna manera si el álbum
en este pánico que estaba hacia dije
bueno ya tengo la solución tengo que
empezar a escribir y dije no quiero ser
víctima
no quiero auto compadecerme y quiero
convertir esta desgracia en la peor
desgracia que me haya pasado en ese
momento en mi vida en algo positivo y
ahí empieza la quijotesca idea de
escribir tú me marca una obra y me voy a
bolivia a mi primera obra como director
y como dramaturgo y ahí se me cierran
todas las puertas y no consigo ningún
auspicio de nadie que quiera apoyar una
obra gay
en ningún momento se anima a hacer esto
hoy es más me dicen que no voy a ser
capaz de encontrar a 30 personas a 30
chicos que se animen y que tengan los
huevos de hacer de gays
y claro él no a mí me empodera y en ese
momento yo digo entonces yo voy a formar
un elenco de cero y encuentro 30 chicos
y los formó como actores físicamente
emocionalmente psicológicamente para que
sean embajadores de una manera diferente
de pensar de pensar en el amor de pensar
en la masculinidad y ahí están mi elenco
en el de los cuales estabas tú yo
así fue como tú me man se estrena y sin
un peso y además mucha gente nos decía
que nos iban a colgar de los juegos nos
está cordadas y es en ese momento que al
día siguiente está sacado del país
exiliada otra exilio nos auguraban sin
embargo el día siguiente del estreno
pasa algo inaudito recibimos decenas
decenas de cartas en facebook tenemos a
una página de facebook de gente contando
su historia su verdad dis contando las
historias de homofobia de suicidio gente
saliendo del closet y me doy cuenta en
ese momento de que mi dolor era el dolor
de mi audiencia y que mi vergüenza ya no
existía sólo había verdad y la gente
lloraba no por mí lloraban por ellos
mismos y la bolivia con la que yo crecía
había cambiado para siempre
[Aplausos]
el 2000 el abril de 2015 se estrena tu
me manco y apenas días después empiezan
a salir del closet chicos en colegios
universidades privadas públicas nos
empiezan a llamar profesores educadores
e incluso políticos para que nos ayuden
a asesorar a estos chicos y ahí vamos
todos los 30 actores para asesorar y
para hablar con estas personas que
estaban dando el primer paso más
drástico de su vida que es vivir su vida
en paz sin nada que temer
sin nada que esconder y ahí es donde me
doy cuenta del emperador empoderados que
es este sistema y ahora dos años después
de esta locura nos preparamos para
estrenar la película dentro de muy poco
la obra de teatro en broadway y muy
pronto la fundación tu mamá
[Aplausos]
este efecto mucha gente lo llamaba el
efecto tú me manga y me hizo recuerdo a
una frase que escuché una vez que la
distancia más corta entre dos personas
es una historia y aprendí el poder de
contar una historia el poder
transformador humanizador empatiza d'or
me di cuenta que nuestra visibilidad es
empoderado ahora pero el empoderamiento
viene con efectivamente mucha
responsabilidad
y hablando de empoderamiento la otra
cara de la otra cara de esto es la parte
de esconder es
que ahora ya son una figura pública
hasta hace tiempo son una figura pública
a toda figura pública siempre está este
tema de que es público que es privado
pero en tu caso tiene un énfasis
especial háblame un poco de eso
mi vida entera tratando analizar lo que
es la privacidad y la privacidad se
entiende como el derecho individual de
decidir qué cómo cuándo dónde ya quién
le permito compartir cierta información
y hay dos tipos de el pensamiento
filosófico sobre la privacidad la
privacidad como intimidad que se refiere
al espacio esa espera de su esfera de
seguridad donde se guarda la intimidad
luego está la privacidad como secreto
que sé que habla exclusivamente de cómo
controlar esa información habla del que
se esconde pero fíjate que ambos
pensamientos son negativos porque hay un
estigma de que hay algo que se esconde
algo que se tiene que proteger algo malo
entonces y mucho más hoy en día con los
sesgos que hay de las nuevas tecnologías
de la vigilancia el internet los medios
sociales
y te cuento por ejemplo hay un sesgo que
se llama el paradigma del secreto que es
la tendencia que tenemos nosotros a
rechazar como privado cualquier cosa que
ya se conoce públicamente es decir si no
es secreto no es privado
entonces como proteges tu ciertas cosas
que tú necesitas que sean visibles
entonces ahí es donde a mí me interesa
buscar su tipo de privacidad una
privacidad que te proteja de ser mal
juzgado o definido fuera de contexto en
un mundo donde la información se conoce
se confunde con conocimiento
la privacidad debería ser la capacidad
de vernos a nosotros mismos de pensar
antes de hablar
y razonar ante nuestras opciones y de
trabajar nuestras ideas de manera
privada antes del consumo público
solamente de esta manera la privacidad
puede servir la causa de la libertad y
no impedirla por eso que a mí me
interese en este mundo de post
vigilancia post post igualidad e incluso
le dicen y post
contemporaneidad de alguna manera me
interesa este tipo de privacidad que
habla de la privacidad como confianza la
premisa de privacidad como lealtad la
privacidad como libertad pero no del
escrutinio de la gente sino la
privacidad como libertad para
construirnos como seres humanos para
realizarnos
somos lo que negamos se llama tu charla
es el título de tu charla
nos parece una hipérbole una exageración
para decir algo pero me gustaría saber
hasta qué punto porque lo que decís es
como que en la oscuridad
ahí está el tesoro no somos lo que me
llamo es así literalmente o eso es una
exageración yo creo que si era el
momento que tu vida corre riesgo por ser
quien eres por esconder lo que eres
y tu visibilidad tu voz tu presencia es
muy importante hoy en día el acto de
salir a la calle como mujer como
homosexual como persona trans como
indígena o como cualquier persona que
esté privada de los derechos
fundamentales básicos civiles humanos
incluyendo su privacidad
es un acto político el estar vivo y ser
diferente hoy es un acto político
porque hoy porque
después de haber hecho un montón de
cosas porque hoy estás en este télex
ante todas estas personas hablando de lo
que estás hablando porque hoy no antes
porque me tomo una vida darme cuenta de
esto
que el arte es la única mentira que
cuenta la verdad
me tomo una vida darme cuenta
podemos contarnos y nuestras historias y
cambiar nuestro destino y que esas
palabras que nos definen están cargadas
de narrativa y de historia por ejemplo
la palabra gay para muchos de ustedes
significa vergüenza débil poco hombre la
palabra que significa el rechazo
significa muerte para mí la palabra gay
significa hijo hermano amigo tío para mí
la palabra que significa belleza
poesía libros arte flexibilidad
elasticidad masculino y femenino para mí
la palabra que significa orgullo
confianza familia comunidad y me
encantaría que a partir de ahora la
palabra que signifique es para bolivia
éxito director de cine director de
teatro creativo amigo
[Aplausos]
bueno he estado muy serio en esta
entrevista disculpa que me desubique
preguntándote lo siguiente
porque te pintan las uñas
parece absurdo pero lo vengo escondiendo
hace mucho tiempo yo me pinto las uñas
desde que murió mi amigo gandalf pero él
siempre que vengo bolivia lo es pinto y
para mí esto es algo que es un
recordatorio un recordatorio de cómo nos
definimos es un reflejo de quiénes somos
es un recordatorio de mi capacidad de
cruzar el umbral del miedo de reclamar
mi curiosidad ir más allá de todo lo que
siempre temía y siempre escondía para mi
es un recordatorio de que éxito
significa ser libertad de ser uno mismo
de que a mí no me interesa ser normal ni
la normalidad
y de que en mi visibilidad radica mi
autonomía
y mi libertad
pintarme las uñas es como un
recordatorio de que tengo una familia
que me ha dado los recursos humanos más
importantes el amor la fuerza y el apoyo
incondicional y ahora escojo compartir
eso con la gente que no tiene esos
recursos humanos porque somos muchísimos
y estamos luchando en todo el mundo
entonces están encerrando enterrando en
el mundo entero nos están matando en el
mundo entero y estamos rezando en todas
partes del mundo y estamos creando en
todas partes del mundo y estamos
llorando en todas partes del mundo y
estamos amando en todas partes del mundo
y estamos viendo en todas partes del
mundo estamos vivos en todas partes del
mundo estamos vivos viejos y eso es una
cosa más importante es un recordatorio
también de qué gandalf tenía razón y que
si se le puede enseñar a volar a las
gallinas y que allá afuera hay alguien
quién sabe donde esté dispuesto a
compartir su vida conmigo sin miedo
y yo podré compartir mi tiempo en mis
años y quizás hasta el reloj que me
sobra
[Aplausos]